- But okay, so you guys are
both pretty easy on the eyes so.
(audience cheers)
I'm just saying.
So, my question is, is it hard?
How do you deal with that?
That's kinda difficult.
- I mean I get it with Michael.
- Oh don't you even.
You're so handsome.
- I can barely turn away
from these deep blue eyes.
- The eyes, it's the eyes.
Yes yes.
- I get it with him.
That's all I can say, yeah.
- But so, I wanna say
though 'cause I was saying
you're both attractive.
We know you're married
and well, he's engaged.
Sorry ladies.
But this is why I'm bringing it up
because it's the sweetest proposal ever
and I want you to tell everyone
and brag about yourself.
- There was a bit before,
like when we were shooting the show
that kinda gave me a bit of a push
'cause I was kinda in my head about it
trying to figure out what to do,
but I remember a scene
where I talked about,
my character says when
something dope comes along,
you gotta lock it down
or else if you're stuck in your thoughts,
you'll miss your opportunity,
and then get sucked into a
propeller of a swamp boat.
That last bit,
- The last bit's not as use.
- Ignore that part.
- Yeah.
- But the first part I really
took into consideration
and I took her to different places,
like where I first saw her,
where we had our first date,
where we had our first
acting class and stuff.
I would take her back to these places
and I would have this message on a canvas
and I'd have her read it and
then we'd go to the next place
and then in the last place,
got down on one knee and.
- [Kelly] Was it your family
that had signs that said
will you marry me and then
you were on your knee?
- Yeah.
- Okay you left out the best part, Manny.
So your family was behind
her and they all had a sign,
so when she turned around
and said will you marry me,
he was on his knees when
she turned back around.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's go good.
- Gotta give it up to the parents.
- Oh my gosh.
What a great family too,
that's so fun to be a part of.